It was white. Yeah. Clarence King. Not to be confused with Sean King, who,
by the way, when we get to the story, I believe that Shaun King,
Shaun Jeffrey King stole Clarence King's story. And that's why he named himself.
Sean King, Clarence King. He named him after Sean K uh, Claire,
Shaun King named herself after Clarence King,
because King is not his family land.
Why not? I mean, it's his real dad was, well, I don't know if it's his real dad.
Probably the dad on his birth certificate is a white man named
Jeffrey K allegedly. No, no, no. That's what's on his birth certificate.
Who knows.
Because he also said that he was a victim of a hate crime and there's no record
of that.
Yeah. There's no record of the hate crime. Absolutely zero. There, there,
the police report, there is a police report of an incident,
but that police report lists him as white.
He says it was a fight between two students.
Actually, Sean King should,
at some point be brought up on federal charges for inciting Ray stuff.
And he actually, he actually is like a real like Devilfish criminal, Sean,
Sean King, because Rachel doll is all in Clarence King. It was kind of,
they didn't really mean to hurt anybody. They were just doing it.
We'll get into the story of Clarence King. They were just doing it for love.
And, but Sean King is actually exploiting people and causing harm.
So I want to see a world where Sean King gets brought up.
It's interesting too, because Sean King has that story of, um,
a hate crime where he said, uh, you know, he missed a year of school.
He had multiple back surgeries.
There's no record of any of that school or the hospital.
And interestingly enough, Rachel Dolezal. Well,
he says he had that hate crime happened to him.
And that's when he chose blackness. After that, cause he was like, all right,
that, that made me black or whatever, which is an interesting story.
Rachel doll was also made up. She,
she was sending letters to herself like Jessie Smollett did Jessie smell that
was sending those hate crime letters to himself, to himself.
Rachel dozer did the same thing in a PO box was she only had the key of, uh,
but the letters would go into there or whatever that she was sending hate crime
letters to herself. And she'd like burned a cross on her own lawn or whatever.
So, but back then.
Do you think you ever think about like a lot of this is just like
entitlement, meaning like the, you know,
people feel entitled for like a lot of reasons. It's like you have to,
because we live in such a world where they're so opposite ends of the spectrum.
Either you need to be a superstar and feel entitled that way,
or you need to be a victim and feel entitled that way.
So I feel like if you can't live in the middle anymore and just being an
average, person's like average and especially American society is just not good.
So these people that feel insanely average, like a Sean King,
like a Rachel doll is all like Jessica crew. Cool.
We'll talk about all three of them. And maybe even like in a way Clarence King,
although we'll get into the Clarence King story, he did it for love.
But these people, because they can't feel just average and mediocre,
they have to pick an extreme and say,
I'm now going to be a victim of race stuff as like a sense of entitlement of to
say I deserve something too, because I can't just be mediocre.
Do you ever think of that?
I do think of that. And I think it's tied to the American dream.
I think it's tied to what America markets, right?
Like you got to make something to check. You got to be some, we looked down on,
on the middle-class on average people in like other countries,
people feel okay with having a job.
Everyone here feels like they have to be a rapper or a celebrity or something.
It's just like those lives. Aren't great. But it's marketed.
Like you have to be famous, even extremely.
Family rich and wealthy and famous people. Most of their day is average.
Yeah. So no matter what, no matter which.
Way you escape, try to slice it. Whether you're a victim,
you want to play the victim and the race card.
And I'm a victimized by everything. And you're on TV for a minute being like,
I'm the victim most of your day. Other than the little part you aren't TV,
you're average, same thing as Drake. Most of his day,
besides when he posts or does the concert at MSG leading up to that?
It's pretty average. He just wakes up in a hotel or his house has breakfast.
Like everybody else brushes his teeth does some other.
And then for two hours in the day, one, whatever, he does a big concert,
but most of Drake's time is just average. So everything,
even if you get to the pinnacle, LeBron James right now. Yeah. Yeah.
He has a playoff game tonight and he has practiced before.
But the rest of it is just average sitting around thinking of to do until he's
got time for the practice of the game. So we're all at.
There's no question. LeBron James wakes up, right? He jerks off.
Maybe he jerks off like a regular, like a hundred percent. He'll be like,
you know what, let me just rub one out.
Yeah, look. Some, some Instagram models,
probably DMS I'm under some fake accounts.
Yeah. And then he goes downstairs. He has breakfast or whatever.
And then he farts. I mean, LeBron James just farts. He takes a nap.
He talks to his kids, you know? So.
You want what these, what people who look at, Oh, I want to be successful.
I want to be celebrity. I want to be this.
What you really want is your they're all everybody's average. You can't,
you can't escape at being average and you can't escape suffering.
So I think as human beings more focused on how do I deal with being average and
accepted and how do I accept suffering? Because from Jeff Bezos,
being the richest man in the world to the homeless guy who eats his own,
they're both suffering.
It's just different forms of suffering happened for different reasons,
but you can't escape either one of them. And this even Bezos,
he's got all the money in the world,
but many parts of his day are just very average. So it's just like,
I don't know what people want this solution. That's why I'm kind of happy.
The Kardashians show,
even though I know it's already ripple effects and all that,
and it's not like it just goes away, but I'm kind of happy.
It's had its time and now it's moving on because it's a little bit like
celebrating these extremes of you got to have this and the big and the big and
this and that. It's really like it with the,
our psyche so much because the truth is,
we're all mostly average and we're all going to suffer and you can't escape
either one of those and the people that do,
I think they go to an extreme either you become Donald Trump or you become Shaun
King. And either way, either I'm going to be noticed because I'm a victim,
I'm going, gonna be noticed. Cause I want to be president United States,
but it's all just trying to escape the fact that you're average and you're going
to stop. It all sounds familiar. So you would think like,
because when you know Sean ping, everybody of course knows he's white.
Even though he keeps saying he's black. It's like, we all know,
and the truth will come out.
Eventually just like Rachel Dole is all who that was like the big news.
And like, how could somebody do that?
How could someone pretend that they were black when they were really white?
And then you see this has been happening throughout history.
So we found the case all the way from the late 18 hundreds where he's doing it.
And you would have to think it's been happening for hundreds and hundreds of
years before that.
And it's probably a lot of people who've done it, who we've never heard of.
He got away with it his whole life. So he didn't do this until like,
this was like the last 13 years of his life.
Of course he didn't predict it could be the last 13.
But in those 13 years he lived a double life.
As James taught by a man named Clarence. Do we think James.
How does a good black name? Is it a cute black name or bruits black?
I think it's a good one. I mean, I was saying.
You're going to go hard and you got like Darnell Rawlings always told me,
go hard or go home. He sh go harder, go home.
I think he should've went blacker and called himself. Donna.
Rawlings. Darnell rocks. Yeah. If I, if I literally, if I,
if I was sticking to this, if I had to do a black name,
I would probably go with a classic one, all New York jets player.
I would go with the brick show at the Stefano. That's what I would say.
I'm the brick short to stuff it up just to get back to Sean King for a second,
no matter which way.
Slice it. Even if he had some really light skin, black ice,
a real improbable story that his mom told him at nine years old.
This is the official story. Is his mom at nine years old, John Kang.
We're talking about the present day, Sean King, the civil, the activity.
If they do is ancestry.com now, and see where's roots came from,
they totally cut, but he won't do it. Of course he will.
He was offered by some conserve, some black conservative.
I think Larry elder offered him $250,000 to the charity of your
choice. If you took it, if you did that.
It says DNA tests. Yeah. Cause if knows, he knows that it's going to come back,
UK baby.
His story is that, uh,
his mom had an affair behind his dad's back and that's he was
this kid of that. And his mom told him at nine years old.
And these are some other conveniently dead right now.
That was mom's still alive. What does his mom say about that?
She has. I don't know, but I don't know if she's alive. I know brother. Yeah.
His brother died, but uh, tragically rest in peace.
His brother down to like leukemia or some cancer. Sorry. Yeah.
But I just thought it was probably hard.
Cause he was dealing with a lot of stress.
Try and keep his brother's dirty little secret.
So I think you killed your brother, Sean King. You piece of.
The mom would tell a nine-year-old kid by the way. No, this isn't your real dad.
Your real dad is some dude. I begged behind his back.
No cheese looks like my friend Mark Hurston,
who I grew up with who was a French Jewish? No look, he looks like.
He could be Puerto Rican for sure. It looks like to be Puerto Rican,
mostly the haircut and the staff. It's mostly the haircuts.
You have a stash like that too. When I was,
when I was trying to look Puerto Rican. Yeah. So black. So when I grew up,
it was very cool. Hip hop culture was very cool.
So Clarence King, Shaun King,
it's interesting that both their last names are King.
I really genuinely in my heart believe Sean King knew about Clarence's King
story and got inspired by it. And even though you say it's birth certificate,
I just don't believe anything comes out of this kid's mouth.
So I think Sean King co-opted Clarence King story and it's just the new King.
So that's just what it is. And I believe much like Clarence King told his wife,
his black wife, you know,
who's who she knew him as James Todd on his actual death bed in 1901 while he
was dying of tuberculosis. He said, by the way, I'm not black.
I'm a white guy. I'm a white and I've left you a fortune.
I think Sean King on his deathbed will tell whoever his wife is at the
time that, Hey, by the way, I've been white this whole time.
We really hope you enjoyed that episode. Whatever it was about,
this is just a stock thing that we're taping on temporary episode.
So go make sure you rate, review us, subscribe,
turn on your notifications, get jiggy with it.
And go to patrion.com/bay Ridge boys where things get real.
Really wild.